hey on today's show we're going to talk
about some adult things we're going to
talk about trauma and intimacy
so watch out for the little ears in the
room we're going to be talking about how
to get your marriage back after you've
had a baby
we're going to walk with a mom through a
deep deep trauma and how she can heal
we're going to talk about the difference
between hustling
and being addicted to work stay tuned
hey what's up what's up i'm john and
this is the dr john dalone show
a live show where we walk and talk
alongside you
about your life about what's going on in
your heart in your mind in your world
in your neighborhood all of it and we're
trying to figure out how to do life
together
we're trying to figure out how to be
human beings again we talk about
everything on the show anything all of
it so no matter what's going on your
heart and your mind or your family
listen you're not by yourself there are
other people who are just like you who
are going through it too
we're going to talk about love
heartbreak parenting challenges
emotional and mental health and we might
talk about how much
i hate autocorrect can we all just agree
that whoever wins the presidential
election by the time this comes out we
we probably still won't have a president
by then we might i don't know drama some
of you just were driving down the road
just when i said that you're like
yes we do okay good we got one whoever
it is let's make the first order of
business
no more autocorrect the other day i
texted my wife and i quote
how was your day sinned and it
autocorrected to
how is your fat how is your fat
she wasn't having a great day and i knew
that which is why i made it a point to
text how ask her how she was doing
in particularly she wasn't having a
great
uh image conscious day and that was the
day
that freaking autocorrect decided to
send her
and i quote how is your fat so let's
just all agree we're done with it
we're done with it so we're gonna talk
about all of it on the show so
whatever's going on
let's do it give me a call at
1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844
or you can email me at askjohn
ramseysolutions.com
all right let's do it let's go straight
to the phones today let's go to
brittany in philadelphia brittany what
is up hi how are you
i'm doing good how are you guys good um
so i was just calling because we had a
baby eight months ago
congratulations thanks boy or girl
boy or girl girl girl what's her name
reagan
oh beautiful i love it i love it okay go
ahead
um and we have had a hard time like
being parents
aside from or sorry being a couple aside
from parents
um and i think a lot of that has to do
with the fact that i had pretty
significant
postpartum anxiety and he has like
virtually no anxiety
and has never dealt with anyone with
anxiety before so that definitely took a
toll
um and yeah so when you say we're having
trouble as a
couple right or we're trying to get our
relationship back on track
tell me what that that awkwardness
explain to me like give me a situation
that awkwardness that weirdness and hey
listen i've been there and so
i know man it's the worst um
walk me through give me a scenario um
i guess a good example
um would be like you know by the time
she goes to bed we're kind of just both
like
okay time to just like hang out in the
couch watch tv and like not talk to each
other
yes and just like chill and not really
do anything
um so tell me about this oh go ahead
tell me about your anxiety yeah
yeah my anxiety caused us a whole lot of
debt
what does that mean what does that mean
so i
i guess a little more backstory um my
i've had a lot of like loss in my life
so my dad passed away suddenly a few
years ago
from cancer my mom was diagnosed when i
was pregnant with cancer
um and so when i was pregnant i was like
okay i'm going to do
anything that i can to keep this baby
healthy including breastfeed
and then i couldn't breastfeed so that
like took a toll on me every day
and then i was like okay i'm just gonna
do
everything to like do what i can control
what i can so if i like bought a box of
diapers and the next day
i saw like a more organic brand i'd be
like oh we gotta go buy this even if it
means putting on a credit card
which was totally unreasonable and we've
my anxiety is much better now because i
got help for it but
it's just definitely caused debt and
stress
and he didn't know how to deal with it
and so yeah
so how has he contributed or tried to
help
um you don't need to do that
everything's okay
it kind of like like you would explain a
fixer gotchas just
he tries to give you some some good
information to where one day you'll be
like
oh you're right i shouldn't be anxious
thanks man i hadn't thought of that okay
yeah
but then a lot of the times it would end
up he'd like get frustrated just be like
fine just go buy it
and then yeah so who
who do you have in your in your sphere
that when things start spinning out when
you get frustrated or
your heart starts racing or you wake up
with those just
brutal intrusive thoughts who
who do you go to who do you call who do
you
text who do you go see
um sometimes my mom okay um
but usually i kind of keep to myself
okay so i want to change some of your
language a little bit
and then work on a game plan is that
cool
so i want to reorient
this idea that anxiety caused
your xyz anxiety caused your
um like when you just get spinning out
about diapers and they got to be super
organic and then there's the super super
organic brand and the whatever
and then you look it up on the internet
and it's like if you put these on your
baby
forever their mitochondria won't grow
and whatever the caustic thing is right
um that's less anxiety
that's more expectations that's more
exhaustion that's more
your body recalibrating chemicals and
hormones that's more loneliness
anxiety is the heart rate the intrusive
thoughts
the can't stop the waking up in the
middle of the night
all that's doing is letting you know
that you don't have these other things
and so what i like to do is take anxiety
when you feel it and just go okay
what am i what am i what is my body
trying to tell me
right is it trying to tell me that i
haven't processed
dad's loss just his sudden passing
and suddenly dad and mom everything can
be moving along and suddenly dad and mom
can just go away
and oh by the way i'm pregnant in the
middle of a worldwide pandemic
and i control very very little and so
i'm going to reach double down and
control
every little thing right so i want to
look at
what the alarms are telling me not blame
and focus on those things okay
so whenever you feel that panic i want
you to stop what you're doing
before you go buy something before you
go to another internet article
and if you're like me when i was
spinning out all the time when i was
just
highly highly anxious
i would walk by hey an aisle and we'll
just use your die for example i'd be
walking by an aisle and i would just
have a box of diapers in my thing and i
would see the word organic and i would
stop and turn and be like what about
these and then i would sit there and i'd
scroll on my phone and i'd google it and
i'd find another one or another one
and yeah then i'd get out of control
instead of doing that instead of getting
more information
i want you to go to part two about what
we're gonna do here okay
so all the things you're experiencing i
want you to know are super normal
you're not crazy okay okay and
there's nothing worse and i haven't been
one so i'm speaking from
folks i've met with not personal
experience but i can't fathom anything
worse than being a new mom
sitting down with a six month old or
seven month old in the middle of a
pandemic
with a husband who desperately loves me
but doesn't know how to connect
and feeling like this is all on me
oh and by the way mom's got cancer right
and that's a harrowing scary lonely
feeling
and so what you've got to do is decide
do i want to live in that
or not and i'm guessing since you called
you don't want to
so here's where you're gonna have to get
highly highly intentional okay
and hey by the way that question i just
asked sounds like i'm being a smarter
like i'm not
there are some folks that want they
don't want to feel bad but they don't
want to give up that control that this
is all on me
right they don't want to forgive
themselves for not being able to
breastfeed
they don't want to forgive themselves
for
my kid is crying in the middle of the
night and i looked it up on the line and
he's supposed to already be sleeping and
he's not and so i've got the one crazy
kid and he's probably got a bit
right they don't want to give that up
and that's fine
they're gonna they're gonna reap what
they sow there they're gonna they're
choosing a life of
spinning out and confusion and
frustration and i'm not minimizing
postpartum that is real and that is evil
but there is some things you can do that
will surround yourself with people to
make sure you're meeting with your
doctor et cetera so
in terms of your relationship right when
you said it
i was i just smiled okay
you have to decide you and your husband
have to decide that the couch
and tv is not an option
you've got to take that off the table
and what that means is you're going to
have to relearn
and i'm not saying this in a silly way
i'm saying this in a totally honest
truthful
moving forward way i've had to do it
myself a couple of times
you're gonna have to relearn how to like
him
and he's gonna have to relearn how to
like and love you and he's gonna y'all
are gonna have to re-learn how to
um find rest in each other
and not in the couch and vegging out
and that means he's gonna have you're
gonna have to be uncomfortable about
your body
and he's gonna have to be uncomfortable
about your discomfort
and he's gonna have to be uncomfortable
about his body because i know he's put
on 30 pounds during this deal
and you are going to have right it's
going to have to be this
coming relearning how to love each other
again
and re-learning how to like each other
again and so yeah
you have to be super highly highly
intentional and that might mean
all you want to do in the world is turn
the tv on and veg out
i want you to turn it off and i want you
to say hey will you just hug me for a
little while i try to lay
on you on the couch and i want you just
to hug me and
something like read to me or i'll read a
book and you read a book or something
ridiculous like that um but i want you
to focus on
each other i also want you to make plans
for intimacy and connection
and this is something that trips up a
lot of couples especially after their
first kid
is when you have no kids you it's just
free-for-all dude right you get home
you're like let's just hook up now it's
five o'clock who cares it's before
dinner it's after dinner it's saturday
morning it's sunday afternoon
it doesn't matter when and then suddenly
this baby comes
and robs you of your
self-esteem it robs you of all of your
energy all of your money
and then you just want to sit on the
couch and let netflix take your
soul from you and so you guys are gonna
have to
rebuild a new relationship in this new
era and what that might mean for a
season
is putting sex on the calendar it's
going to be hey
tuesday night a sexy night tuesday night
and friday nights these are sexy nights
and you can get one pass a month or
something right like
hey i guess that's a good thing to
mention is that there's been literally
zero of that
that's right that's right hey you're not
it's not uncommon right everybody's
exhausted
everybody's hormones all over the place
everybody looks differently than they
did
a year and a half ago and it just
becomes this weird thing and he doesn't
know how to approach you
and then you feel awkward don't approach
him that's too super normal
but you got to decide we're going to put
this on the calendar and we're going to
figure out how to make this happen
and um lean into that and my hope is if
you go into it with a spirit of
adventure
and a spirit of not that we're doing
something wrong but that we're building
something totally new
kind of like y'all are just dating again
and you would waste a whole movie just
trying to hold his hand or hoping he
would just brush his fingers up by yours
you know what i mean
you're back to that now and so enjoy it
in a exciting fun way not a oh my gosh
we have to do all this over again
because you're going to find different
things about yourself you're gonna find
different things about him
and the cool thing is you're gonna have
to actually talk about it for the first
time in a long time
my my hope is this being highly
intentional
about connection then that desire will
return
and then you're gonna have to be the
this is the final thing
be really intentional about getting
sleep about
setting boundaries with your kid about
exercising about going outside even when
it's cold
and doing some of those things that make
you a human again
postpartum robs you of yourself and
struggling loving somebody who's
struggling with postpartum
robs him of his what he felt like his
control and power and gift in your
relationship was was
knowing the answers it steals that from
him too so y'all just sit there at a
loss right
yeah and i guess a lot of my guilt is
like 100 of the debt is from me
and like my like rebuying wanting to get
the best of everything and like he
has always been like super good with
money so now we're like in this hole and
it's like
oh sorry that was all me well so here it
is
then you sit down and you say i i'm
sorry
i own this debt and i'm gonna say when
you're in a married relationship
um don't change the pronouns right at
any point he could have said hey you're
struggling right now
i want to intervene and he didn't so
everybody owns everything you deciding
to take all that on and then where all
that guilt is just going to crush a
relationship
and it's going to make you a little less
likely to
initiate intimacy or connection it's
gonna make him feel like
well here we go again right so yeah i
would
set up some time and say here's what
we're gonna do starting
this week we're going to put sex on the
calendar
we're going to intentionally turn the tv
off even if we
just stare at each other it's going to
be awkward and weird we're just going to
hold hands and make out again we got to
figure out how to do this again
and we're going to enjoy it we're going
to be open and say i actually didn't
like that
or i did love this or or or
and you're going to say hey i spent a
lot of crazy money here's the big secret
your kid has no idea what the best of
anything is
you know what i mean they don't they
have no idea um
they can use a seventh removed blanket
from goodwill
just throw the washer and your kid will
be fine right and so you can say
hey honey i want you to help hold me
accountable i'm gonna give you my debit
card for the foreseeable future because
while i'm learning to not be anxious
anymore um i can't control my spending i
had to do that with my wife
by the way brittany i did that i gave my
wife my debit card when my son was born
because i was
out of my mind and so we actually did
that he does all the money now
well i s but i see and what happens is
you get these little seeds of separation
and suddenly it's gonna you're gonna
wake up and it's gonna be two years
and you're gonna have sex five times in
those two years
and and i'm not being gratuitous i'm
just telling you that's what's gonna
happen he's gonna do all the money
you're gonna be totally separate from it
then you're gonna start thinking things
like i do everything around here i can
buy whatever i want
and that's when you go get your secret
credit card or you go to the bank and
get your own debit card again right so
it just
creates this gap and what i want you
guys to do is to be
super highly highly overly intentional
about reconnecting that gap right now
right bringing it back together
and um having some very direct
conversations
sorry about the debt that's on both of
us i'll own it
we got to be done with that starting now
here's the credit card but i still want
to do the budget with you every week
i've got to be connected there we put
sex on the calendar
we're gonna be open and talk about sex
what do we like what do we not like
what's this new season this new world
we're building we're gonna not
we're gonna get board games we're gonna
get silly games we're gonna do things
together besides just hitting the couch
and my guess is after a week after two
weeks of reconnecting
the time spent in front of the the tv is
going to be smaller and smaller and
smaller because you're going to realize
you like that guy and he's going to
remember that he likes you
and expect it to be awkward expect it to
be weird and uncomfortable
that's good stuff it's part of it of
re-learning how to love each other after
bringing another human into your home so
brittany you're not crazy you're right
where you need to be
um final final thing you got to get some
friends
you have to get some friends that's not
your mom you've got to get some friends
that's not your husband some folks you
can call when you're having a low day
when you're having a is this normal day
this feels weird day
my kid's not doing x y z and i know what
to do day be
intentional be intentional call old
friends from college if you have to
call friends from your local community
group or your church if you have to i
don't care
you got to got to got to have friends
okay you got to connect with people
and then of course i'm telling you this
brittany i'm telling anybody struggling
for postpartum
if you have intrusive thoughts that get
real dark
and those of you who have been through
that know what i'm talking about
you got to reach out and call somebody
you got to call for help you gotta call
a counselor you gotta call your ob gyn
call your doctor
um but do not sit at home by yourself in
the dark
wondering what you're doing as a mother
you have a role as a mom
you're the greatest gift on planet earth
and i want you to honor and love
yourself so brittany you are the best
thank you for the call
i'm so excited for a beautiful little
reg and she's gonna have two awesome
parents
um i want you to call me back if you
will after you have this first call
i mean this first meeting with your
husband after you sit down and say all
right
we're rebuilding i love you you love me
that sounded like the barney song a
little bit that got weird but um
you love each other we're gonna rebuild
this thing i want you to call me back
and let me know how that conversation
goes i'm looking forward to it um all
right let's go to
lauren in salt lake city lauren how are
we doing this morning
oh i'm doing all right thank you so much
for taking my call and sharing your
insight
thank you for calling it's it's it's
super early there huh
it's pretty early yeah well thanks for
waking up with us this morning
yeah so how can i help lauren
so uh last fall we had two hard things
happen um
in sequence and um one of the things is
um last fall i was picking up my
ten-year-old son from football practice
as we were pulling out of the parking
lot
i accidentally ran over another little
boy
um with my car and it was
terrible and um hold on take a breath
take a breath take your breath
you're good anyway
so i find myself struggling
um with anxiety from that
um here we are in the
football season again and um
you know i'm finding myself not wanting
to you know pick him up from practice
again of course and
you know even go to his games or
anything and
um so i'm just oh and
the little boy is okay
he's he's all right um now so um
just to throw that in there but um
so take a breath and i'm going to recap
while you're taking a breath okay so
okay last year during your little boys
football practice
you're leaving practice and you
accidentally
ran over um another little boy in the
parking lot
and um when people think of that
and again i'm not going to be overly
gratuitous but i've been in these trauma
situations and i want people to
understand what happens in your heart
and mind here
my guess is there were yells and sounds
and things that you saw that people are
not supposed to hear and see is that
right
yeah okay definitely not good
yeah there you go and those things
replay themselves
over and over and over right um and then
all of a sudden that
um the boy's okay
right he recovers he's running around
like a normal little boy now
he is okay a miracle really yeah he's
totally fine and the family how do they
hold you responsible do you still
connect with them what's that
relationship like
um no no i'm there
um i i
forced myself to you know go see see
them afterwards
um just so i could see him normal
you know like um not in that
state and um you know to tell her you
know
you know just give her flowers and stuff
um
you know she was nice you know of course
in the moment that was
not good but um uh afterwards
you know she was very nice and um
yeah proud of you for doing that that's
a hard thing to do and um
it's a it's that was an act that will
serve you years to come
seeing him with your own two eyes
running around seeing that family again
um that's gonna pay dividends
years down the road and so now it's
football season again
and you don't want to even go near that
place you don't want to be around that
place and you said there was two things
going on what's the second thing
oh well the second thing was like the
day
after that happened i was you know
obviously having a hard time and
um stuff and my husband found out um his
mom had passed away
um unexpectedly and so jeez okay hold on
a second that was
you just you passed that along just
dismissively you're like oh and by the
way
um i went and got burritos at the local
gas station like
no that's a big big family trauma right
it was yeah yes um
it was and so my guess is you didn't get
to grieve at all you turned into
taking care of him taking care of
everybody around is that right
yeah that's exactly right he you know he
looked at me and he just said i
i need you right now i just you know
i knew that he did you know at that
point we knew the little boy was gonna
be okay
and i just was like okay you know so i
just really pushed everything
down and didn't really i don't know i
think i just ran away from it
and so well you ran away in the name of
duty right
um yeah right so if you think if you
think of your feelings
you took yours with two hands and you
compress them
and another word for compress is to
depress right
you yeah depressed them down so that you
could take care of your husband
and your husband's family and probably
your kids and
because they lost their their grandma
and you did a noble thing in a hard
thing
in counseling we call it leakage which
is if you don't deal with past
trauma they will eventually make their
way out usually at a real inopportune
time
they don't ever go away right and
lucky for you and i'm saying this on
purpose lucky for you
they're coming out a year later and
they're coming out in a situation that i
think
that you could you're going to be able
to rally your heart and mind around and
heal from okay
um so tell me about uh the intrusive
thoughts
what pops into your head when you're
driving down the street when you pull
into a grocery store parking lot tell me
about that
yeah uh
just i think just i don't know like
if i feel a bump you know under the car
or something air
yeah your whole body just floods right
yeah
yeah just you know heart rate just
sometimes they feel like oh this is a
little dangerous you know
yeah yeah anyway you know i just i do
feel like i have like these anxiety
attacks
um and you know
eventually they kind of fade and i'm
okay but
you know i just i feel like i don't want
to
go to that parking lot again and you
know i feel like i'm not supporting you
know i don't know yeah totally like i'm
not
so let me one last question i've got for
you guys i'm kind of wrapping up what we
can do here wrapping my head around
what what i can recommend for you do you
still wake up and i'm saying still
because i 100 know i've met with a
thousand people in your situation
that's probably an overstatement but um
do you still wake up in the middle of
the night
um or has that gone away not not
some not waking up as much um
you know when you wake up is your heart
racing already or are you
are you able to wake up and are you able
to sleep a full night
i'm a yeah i'm i'm sleeping sleeping
okay
awesome awesome good yeah okay
all right so here's um here's a couple
of things some of this you've probably
heard me do on the radio before
and but i want to do it with you and
then i'm going to give you kind of a
game plan and a road map is that cool
yeah that sounds great okay here's the
first thing
you have to decide
and only you can decide this okay you
have to decide that
this is not going to be your identity
and that you don't want to keep
wrestling with this
and until you decide that your brain
is going to continue to try to take care
of you and everyone
around you by sounding every alarm it
has every time it gets in a situation
that it remembers is dangerous
and often people in your situation
sentence themselves
to a life in prison
for an accident yeah
until you pardon yourself
until you say all right i have
i have beat myself up for a year and
i'm ready for this not to be ident my
identity i'm ready to not be the lady
who ran over the little boy
i'm ready to be the awesome mom who
loves my kid
the awesome wife who loves my husband
the awesome community member who has ups
and downs in our life like everybody
else
and when you're ready for that to be
your identity not the worst thing that's
happened to you that you did
and let me be honest if you are texting
and emailing
and trying to eat fast food in your lap
at the same time
i don't care what happened happened and
now we're a year later
and so i want you to decide
that you're gonna let yourself out of
jail okay
because by not letting yourself out of
jail you are making sure that you will
never heal
the people who love you will never heal
and the people around you will never
heal
so i want you to say i forgive me and
now we're gonna be about healing
okay i want you to close your eyes
right we're here on the phone and anyone
listening to this
podcast i want you to close your eyes
and i want you to picture
i don't know um a monkey on a motorcycle
okay just a monkey on a motorcycle and i
wanted to have like a yellow hat
curious george style and i want you to
um
the i don't know i want the the
motorcycle to have like a little side
cart on it right
you got that in your mind yeah okay so
open your eyes
you have just proven to me and to all
the people listening to this and there's
a lot of people listening
that you can when you decide to you can
control your thoughts
and so what you're going to have to do
is this you're going to have to retrain
your brain
to not focus on those moments and it's
going to sound something like this
you're going to be driving along and
you're going to hit a pothole
and your body is going to remember
your amygdala your brain is going to
remember
oh i remember what that means and it's
going to flood you it's going to make it
when your stomach's all warm and your
heart starts racing
that cortisol and adrenaline is going to
dump into your body your hands are going
to get sweaty
and you're going to remember that little
boy's foot you're going to remember
something unique about that situation
and i want you in that moment to go nope
right and then here's what i want you to
do i want you to remember him
at his house playing after he was okay
you get to choose which one of those
thoughts you dwell on
and your brain has a vested interest in
you dwelling on the bad stuff because it
doesn't want that to happen again
and it's not gonna happen again because
you're gonna be a safe driver you're
going to
recognize that was a one in a trillion
accident
the kids shoot out from behind people in
parking lots all the time in ball field
you know ball field parking lots
and that you're going to choose to think
of something positive about him and my
promise to you is over time you will
readjust that default setting
in your brain okay it will recognize oh
it doesn't need me to protect
myself from that anymore the second
thing is
i want you to go to that parking lot
with a friend that you trust
when there's nobody there on a sunday
afternoon
on a monday morning and i want you to
practice
driving in and parking and backing up
and parking
but listen in the nerd world they call
it exposure therapy
right i don't think you need a therapist
to do this i think you need to get a
friend with you
you got to have somebody and probably
not your husband because he's going to
try to
teach you what you're doing wrong you
need a friend just to be with you
right and i want you to go there and
back up
and pull in and then i want you to back
up and pull in
and if you need to get out of the car
and take a walk great
you're gonna have a friend with you if
you need to yell and scream and cry and
swear and do all the things
great you have a friend with you if you
all need to jam on some old motley crew
records whatever you'll have to do in
that moment
but i want you to practice and i want
you to do this a couple of times
and then when you feel comfortable and
you never comfortable's not a good word
when you
feel safe not comfortable because it's
going to be uncomfortable for a while
i want you to drive your son to practice
and park as far away from possible at
the very very back of a parking lot
okay and you are going to slowly ease
your way back into this and when you do
you're going to constantly be monitoring
your thoughts for truth
right okay i want when you have those
feelings that you're a bad driver you're
a terrible person what kind of idiot
neighbor
or mom would fill in the blank i want
you to demand
evidence from those feelings because
they lie to you
okay okay they lie to you
and so in review i want you to decide
and this is this is on your timetable
but my guess is
your husband loves you your kids love
you and they're ready to have their mom
back
and my guess is that you're ready to
have you back
you decide that this is not going to be
your identity you are not the worst
thing that you've ever done
you're not and that you want to heal
you're going to let yourself out of the
prison that you've placed yourself
okay number two i want you to start
practicing controlling those thoughts
and it's going to be a pain
and it's going to be hard but and it's a
daily thing
right and then the number three i want
you to get a friend or two
make an event of it and i want you to go
when that parking lot is empty and
practice driving in and backing up
until you can do it to where your heart
rate is just normal
and then the final thing is i want you
to take your son to practice and park as
far away from everybody as possible in
the far corner of that parking lot
and you're gonna slowly ease yourself
back into this okay
very few people will be watching and
staring at you
and you think they're all going to be
remembering you as the lady that did xyz
they're not they're worried about their
own drama their own election
nonsense or their own covet they're
worried about that stuff
okay yeah so when i tell you those four
things how does that hit you in your
heart
um scary initially
um but oh
yeah scary but um that i
i think that would help just you know i
can see how that would
would help to go there with nobody there
and it's not so similar you know and
try to kind of work through that and you
know
controlling my thoughts and not letting
hey lauren get away from me
lauren you've got to let you off the
hook
you are the last person to forgive you
and today is that day
okay so when
we get off this call i can hear it on
you
i can hear it on you when we get off
this call
the first thing i want you to do is to
go into your bedroom or go into a home
office or go into your garage
and i want you to write yourself a
letter that says
um i forgive you i want you to address
it to you
you got it okay
yeah you do not deserve to carry this
around you for the rest of your life
it happened you've been forgiven you've
got to forgive you
okay yeah that's where healing starts
in this together yeah yeah
awesome yep so here's what i want you to
do
after you go to the parking lot a few
times i want you to email me back i want
you to call me
and let me know how that went i want to
know how your heart was racing
how your friend was cheering you on or
making fun of you if they're a friend
like i have
and laughing all i want you i want to
know how that went but i know you can do
it
and for crying out loud lauren you've
got to forgive you
and everyone listening to this
everybody is involved in accidents
everyone does things that they wish they
could have back
they all make mistakes and we just live
in this world where nobody forgives each
other anymore especially ourselves
and that's got to stop because you just
live out of your pain
then you live out of these bricks in
your backpack that you're the only one
putting them in there
so lauren set the backpack down write
yourself a letter today
that says dear lauren this happened then
i'm sorry
and i forgive you you're a good mom
you're a good wife you're gonna heal
from this and the healing starts today
with letting you off the hook awesome
awesome thank you so much for that call
all right let's go to
rebecca in tampa florida rebecca what is
up
hi dr john thank you for taking my call
thank you for calling how are you
pretty good excellent definitely yeah i
definitely have an interesting
uh question for you all right bring it
on let's do it
uh so my husband and i are really at a
crossroads
with my in-laws and family
my niece uh who's a very young miner
recently gave birth
to a baby with her boyfriend who's also
a minor
how young minor um 15.
okay yes uh it's
a very complicated and tough situation
um right now the mother my niece is
trying to decide what to do with the
child
um what is that okay go ahead go ahead
sorry probably another call yeah
the crossroads is that there are a
couple options on the table
and a few of them are
very tough
maybe possibly even unsafe options for
the baby
and my husband and i don't know how
involved
to get uh to fight for
you know the best situation for the
child
um so if there is less than optimal
situations
or things that you wouldn't do
that's one thing if there's ever in any
circumstance in any neighborhood in any
home
in any family system a situation where a
kid is not
safe then my expectation is that every
adult
in the neighborhood in the family
walking down the street every stranger
goes into that situation kicking and
screaming on behalf of that child
that's my that's my two cents on that so
give me an example of what you feel is
uncomfortable or a little bit weird
you're being kind of vague
so walk me through a couple of
situations here
okay um so the first option
is that my sister-in-law has offered to
adopt the baby she
still is at home with her parents and a
couple
other of her siblings that are
in their mid to late 30s
um one of them struggles with substance
abuse
and is really really deep in that it's
been
many many years and is not
someone that i would consider safe
around children
or babies especially he's
known to be violent with animals uh
never been
um abusive towards a kid that we know of
but has also never lived with one
sure um so that's situation number one
okay so they so they're gonna be they're
going to be and i want to i want to
parse that out real quick
she might get adopted by her sister
right
um sister-in-law or her
boyfriend's sister right
no so it's my niece's aunt my
sister-in-law
uh okay okay your sister-in-law okay so
she might get adopted there
into a house where there's a bunch of
adults living there which
wouldn't be how you would draw it up but
isn't necessarily a bad thing there's
lots of families that have lots of
interesting um intergenerational
dynamics and people coming and going
and that may not be how i draw it up but
i'm not always have a problem with that
particularly
there's lots of different ways that
culturally that families live together
and that's
beautiful and it's okay for how they
choose to do it it's not how i do it but
it's how they do how they do it
but then you added another thing which
is there's somebody there that's an
addict
that's got violence history towards
animals he's not a safe guy and you are
worried about a baby being put in that
environment okay so that's number one
what's the second one
yep um the second one is that at this
young age
um they're encouraging her to go out on
her own
and raise the child
which is scary for us because
um i mean her
and her boyfriend that they are both
very young
and they both come from broken homes and
haven't had a great example
of what it should look like to raise a
child
um i mean that's that's a that's a
really tough road to hoe for a 15 year
old girl by herself
out on her own are you all in a position
to take her in
what's your what's your solution to that
challenge
um well so we live very far away
um we have offered to adopt the baby
um we would not um
at this time be interested in taking
them in as a
a unit all three of them the boyfriend
the mother and the baby um
but that is i mean that's
as far as we've sort of been able to
come up with there's
there doesn't really seem to be i mean
it's such a emotionally
like intense situation what did people
say when you
when you offered to you and your husband
offered to adopt the baby what was the
response
well so it was communicated to my
in-laws not to the mother directly
because it's only been a couple days
since birth she's still recovering
from a slightly traumatic birth but
um response good from one
um maybe not so much from the other
because they don't want the baby to be
far away
sure so i fully support
you adopting the baby if that's what
y'all want to do
i fully support you guys having her and
the baby move in
because then at that point you're
basically adopting a teenager and
um that little baby so you're becoming a
grandma all right instead of a
um adoptive mother i fully support you
not having all three of them move in
i don't want two teenagers who are not
married living in my house
raising a kid because then you've got
children raising a child and it's gonna
get messy messy messy and messy
and family members of his side are gonna
come out of the woodwork
right and when they start to find out
about this baby and it's just going to
be
a mess as far as you know of that baby
possibly going to live in a situation
where there's an
addict and there's safety concerns
there's violence in that home there's
adults coming and going particularly
drug trafficking coming and going dude
i'm gonna go
bang and yell and be loud with one
caveat
if you and your husband have had a hard
conversation about
do we want to expand our family and this
is gonna be that baby
then you are have emotionally invested
in that baby
and the temptation is to start looking
at every other situation is less than
what you would do
and less than what you would give and
there comes a moment when you start
imposing your values and your judgments
on
everything else because quote unquote
that's my baby now
and anything less than that maybe coming
to your house is
a loss for you guys right and so if you
all have gone through that hard
conversation
less about we're gonna rescue that baby
and more we're gonna expand our family
and those are two
totally separate conversations um
because one you rescue the baby then you
figure out what to do later
like i'm getting that baby out of a
burning building right now and then
we're gonna figure it out
the other is no i'm committing to the
next
for the rest of my life i'm the baby's
mother i'm going to adopt her and raise
her as my own
and in conjunction with her 15 year old
mother
you are making a decision to have a
complex
enriched beautiful challenging life
which is honorable and noble and
extraordinary
but you have to temper that with other
situations that might have to happen to
that baby
right and so there's a difference
between having an uncle that smokes weed
and there's that's not
it's against the law and dumb i don't
like that around my kid
and then there's a difference between
someone's violent and they are an addict
and they are bringing hard drugs into
this house and they are does that make
sense you know what i mean
so it's just tempering your heart and
your plan for moving forward
and so i am a thousand percent on board
if the baby's gonna go to an unsafe
situation
go for it if the baby is
um if you all want to adopt this child
you'll have to go and be very very vocal
and be very direct
and probably get in the car and tell
people that you're coming and you want
to have a hard conversation about this
baby
and meet with the 15 year old and the 15
year old's mother
and the 15 year old's father if he's
still in the picture and because this is
still a minor
right and at the end of the day
sometimes you've got to let the
beginning part of this play out knowing
that we're going to pick this baby up in
foster care because they're going to try
a scenario 1 or scenario 2 and it's not
going to work and the baby's going to be
welcome to come live with us
and it's a hard messy family situation
but don't hesitate
ever if you think that baby is not safe
is not um gonna be okay
that you don't reach out to the
authorities right away get
super involved get other people who know
what they're doing super involved
right away but it's noble that you want
to be a part of this
this baby's life a 15 year old is still
a child
a 15 year old is still a child
and they need to be honored like a child
even though they're now thrust into
adulthood
so have a hard conversation with your
husband and go make your move um
i appreciate you rebecca that's hard
it's really hard and i appreciate you
guys wanting to be
involved in it make sure you temper your
desire for this baby
the desire to rescue this kid and to
raise this kid with it
he may or she may end up in other
situations they're gonna look different
but may not be terrible
but if they are terrible call the
calvary all right let's go to one last
call here let's go to james in oshkosh
wisconsin
man i'll tell you what um i'm gonna date
the show here
but today's election day when i'm
recording this am i allowed to do that
james
and the three calls today have been from
pennsylvania in florida and wisconsin
the swing states man good for you guys
all right so james so what's up brother
from from oshkosh green bay what's up
hey dr dolony how are you doing this
morning i'm doing good my man how can i
help
uh just first off i wanted to tell you
how much i'm loving the show so far it's
been a great
addition to the ramsey network thank you
so much brother i appreciate it
uh so i just had uh more of a brief
question
uh where i was wondering if you could
provide some clarification
you got it what's up uh i was wondering
at what point
do you simply go from hustling to get
ahead
to becoming a workaholic especially for
those of us that are in baby step
four and beyond as well as if you are
a workaholic and have stepped over that
line how do you
break that addiction to work hmm okay so
um for those who don't know what baby
steps are i'm gonna put it in the show
notes here
um he's talking about dave ramsey's baby
steps to get out of debt
and um the first three steps
are recognizing you got a problem and
getting an emergency fund together
and then running like crazy he calls it
gazelle intense to get out of debt
pay things off and then you want to get
an emergency fund so that if things
happen
not if when things happen you're going
to borrow from yourself not from a
credit card
and you never have to be in debt you
never have to be a slave to somebody
else to some big company
to some department store ever again so
then when you get into baby step
four right like james is talking about
here baby step four
is um starting to save for retirement
i'm gonna pay my house completely off
i'm saving for my kids college and so j
what we what we find often james is that
folks get
gazelle intense and they're hustling
right you got a side job you got two
jobs you got three jobs because you're
doing everything you can to get this
debt paid off as fast as possible
and then that hustle becomes a way of
life you get to where you start running
everywhere
right and at some point that stress
destroys your relationships and destroys
you
fair yep okay
so i here's how i delineate the two
hustling is has a goal to it
i'm going to try to pay this stuff off
i'm going to have a second and a third
job
so that i can get that emergency fund so
that i can finally be safe
i'm gonna picture a gazelle and i'm
gonna sprint through this
land where there are lions until i can
get on high ground where i can see
all around me and then i can stop for a
second and rest and eat
and rejoin my community right
a a workaholic is somebody who is
making their identity by how busy they
are it's an addiction
it's the same addiction as alcohol
as food as like sex and pornography
addiction is addiction as addiction is
addiction and so
the way i would tell you james that you
know you have crossed the line between
hustling
and workaholic that you are addicted to
busyness
is when you shift from working with a
a partner with an accountability person
with your spouse
towards a common goal we're going to
live in a crazy season and pay all this
junk off
my wife and i did that we sold our house
moved into a residence hall we paid off
i think it was 106 grand
in um in a year a year and a half we
went
nuts i was working three jobs she was
working one full-time job
and we had a two-year-old and we had we
lived in a residence hall in a dorm
we sucked it up for a crazy sprint and
then we couldn't keep living like that
if you find yourself addicted to work or
you're avoiding
relationships where you're staying at
work an hour or two later
and you're not going home if when your
wife or your kids go to bed you're
looking for another job and another job
and another job and
james i've been there dude um when you
are when you meet somebody and they say
hey
um my name's rick what's your name and
you say hey i'm james i'm and you
the next thing you give is your job
you've got a problem
you are making your identity about what
you do not about who you are
and so when you make your identity about
what you do
then the temptation is to be leaning on
that all of the time
and i will tell you now i'll tell
everybody this
over and over and over especially men
are
are socialized to have their value and
their worth beyond what they achieve
what they accomplish somebody uh sent me
a
instagram once that was like you're
wrong deloney it's not human beings
it's human doings they're only worth
what they do bullcrap
bullcrap on a stick in a box with a bow
on it
it's ridiculous you got
value and when you start using your work
to numb
feelings to numb disconnection to give
you an excuse to not go home
to not go out and be with your friends
if you're single that's when you know
you've got an addiction
if you can't go through a weekend
without checking your email
if you can't take a vacation if you
haven't taken a vacation in three years
and four years
and that's just rolling up and up and up
if you're sick and you're going to work
anyway
that's when you know it's awesome
awesome question james we get that
a lot here and i want folks to know who
you are is not what you do who you are
it's not how busy you are
that's a crazy endless way of living
your life that
only creates graves and punishment for
everybody
and um good for you brother thank you so
much for calling james
all right as we wrap up today
today's song of the day is this
pulling out my lyrics of the day on my
paper
it's from one of my favorite bands of
all time they're not a well-known band
but they're incredible
and this particular record went wholly
unnoticed it was when
all the record laborers were
consolidating and someone under
and this record came out and then went
away
it's from the 2000 record jesus hits
like the atom bomb by one of my favorite
bands of all time tripp and daisy
the song is called sonic bloom
and on election day i don't know when
this is coming out but today
people are heading to the polls to vote
here's what i want to remind people
they write love gets inside of you
it makes me invisible and i will
continue to hang on
super love a sonic bloom a total
emotionless excuse i can't believe it
happened to me
the magic's in my heart believe me
rushing through
my electrical phase i found a place to
hide when you're away
almost caught myself a breath i touched
your hand and lost myself instead
swung my hands up through the air
northwest skies i love the way you shine
i want to be just as good i want to make
it better
love it gets inside of you tripping
daisy
let's go forward with love good folks
this is the dr john dolone show